тоді уколи щоразу про крим заходи
молу я здається
найкраща дипломатія ось cd монстру
від та нашого ризикового за посаду та
від загальної казав
я copy від руки почувли вала країну
тримав у такі ложки годину я до
здобула авторитет
по всьому світу ти збитий
весна по воді в себе я квал колоди
структур більше черву ція просимо з
бровою
армія
щоб вона ми можемо на очах ви захочете
нашу державу
плітка на провини і продовжи vaio далі
роботи
роботи худої mageia
польші червовим батька та дипломатія
розуміє і ось ще вчора стало з
багато слив про counter нас тут ось я
думаю що вчора такі переломний момент
в циві не прямий і показав і
контр наступають ось такі ось у таку
форму за раз сьогоднішніх реаліях вини
ось c і контур наступав і ти грієш
варварів у його лігві давимо вашшуна
завжди прийшов девін до монстрів висимо
років у повинності в тому ще крим царі
росія а
наші громадян та перилою і вірять україні
і ось такі вчорашні такі дивани дають
у помістивши без борід б там у тилу сну
ходу в руках ворога
вкрадена деморалізує і ми вчора все
бачіли сьогодні з продовжується криму
якуну тягають як паніка і
він і шинки що це таке зброя україну
Можливості ризиковий можеш вивести мету
крейсер таки званий москва c і
d яки
удари по мелітополь у бердянську вирішимо за
хобл іншим місцям
херсонщини за париже і я км і
наші скронь і демонструють
можливості свої до 100 ватів
ніхто не ховається і до лаборантів ти
їж ми шкірного не обидва чума яскравих
автомобіля їх треба раніше і
ось цей нам дає пам'ятаю ще ми додому
обшукавши крил player намаз
або допомагати ризиковим хто чим може
і
ось кольори до почуття його допомога
є ціни 1
така ось
такі дерева та робот порошенка
каша робот команда порошенка
його противники та
думають далі буду ще більше так
помовч скокову нашої команди особиста
самого порошенка знімку виступаю seven
настінку
всі колір деталі знаючи нас кілька в тому
розуміються на спід я не знаю ще
потрібно для ризикових
що ще c
викликає тільки допоможу топ то люди на
читка орендується у всіх аспектах
розвитку жити та від'єднував і нашого
українців
купував він їхньому коридорі